i want to wish everyone across the
united kingdom a very happy new year
usually of course people across the
country will be gathering with their
friends their families
and their loved ones reflecting on
what's going on and looking forward to
everything that is to come
but 2020 has reminded us just how
uncertain
life can be the coronavirus has changed
all of our lives
britain's suffered more than almost any
other major economy
too many of our loved ones have lost
their lives
too many good businesses have struggled
too many people have
lost their jobs and restrictions no
matter how
necessary have been difficult for all of
us
the hidden costs of the pandemic have
sometimes felt overwhelming
people's mental health has suffered
we've missed each other
and some days it feels like the pandemic
will never end
but at the start of the new year there
are reasons to be optimistic
optimistic at the distribution of the
vaccine
optimistic that we will once again hold
loved ones and
have our freedom that our economy can
start growing
businesses can start trading and we can
focus
on the task at hand of rebuilding our
country
but until then it is all of our duty
to stay safe to look after our neighbors
keep up the national effort that has got
us this far
because when this crisis ends and it
will end
we will rebuild our country together
this should be inspired by the bravery
and heroism of those who've been on the
front line since the start of the
pandemic
our key workers our carers nhs workers
police officers those who kept our
streets safe
and our supermarkets stopped at the peak
of the crisis
the united kingdom is forging a new path
in the world
and the labour party that i lead will
focus on ensuring that
that path leads to greater prosperity
to fairness and opportunity for
every nation and region every village
every town and city
that makes up our great united kingdom i
believe this can once again
be the best country to grow up in and
the best country
to grow old in and with that hope and
that vision
i believe that our best years are still
to come
so wherever you are however you're
spending this season
on behalf of the labour party i wish you
a happy new year